guys this is how ghetto of a location
we're in right now look at this I don't
think we've ever put this on my channel
ever you change one man's life on the
fate of the world has been changed
that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
you
day four of my spring trip to
Philadelphia in Palm Springs it is early
I'm leaving Philadelphia today going to
Palm Springs and gonna take you guys
with me one of the things I love doing
what I'm at an Airbnb is just making the
place seem untouched so yeah I
recognizes somebody's home and yeah it's
the second home and it's a business for
them but I know that somebody it's not
you know Sun up it's not a big
corporation so I try to lead the place
like we found it as if I wasn't here and
one of the biggest ways to do that is to
make the bed so yeah what I travel and
use Airbnb I always make the bed
[Music]
there you go well it takes a couple
minutes great improvement show some love
so anytime I have a morning commitment
flight meeting anything if it's before I
usually wake up I tend to not sleep very
well so my goal is to get up at 5:00 and
pick my flight so I ended up waking up
at 2 and then I woke up before and then
I said ok 4:45 just gonna get out of bed
but good news is it's not even 5:00 yet
and I'm gonna head to the airport yeah
Palm Springs he would come I won't be
late
[Music]
let's see where I'm killing the Parcher
do you guys see it I'm a blind all right
figure out where we're going so on top
of having to find my gate I also need to
find a Starbucks
friend of ours
collect Starbucks mugs from different
cities not a cities that he goes to
necessarily just the cities in general
so I think most of his collection has
come from me to be honest
come on Tony let's just come from me so
every time I'm at a new airport that he
hasn't been to I need to look for a
Starbucks Oh Tony I'm looking for you
man okay
figured out the gate issue cuz I'm not
going to Palm Springs I might go in
direct flight I'm going to Denver when a
Denver then connecting and then going to
Palm Springs how I found my gate to
Denver now I need to find the Starbucks
or Tony I'm set to go and leave Philly I
think I see it Tony I think I see it
there it is found it there's a lineup
though Tony you make me stand in this
lineup that appreciate it
let's check that you have him hug first
all right gonna stand in line
Philadelphia
[Music]
Oh feel that heat holy cow
that heat is real all right
Landon Palm Springs now I'm gonna meet
up with a fan
Leo fan of the channel who we're gonna
meet and go film some content drive
about an hour out of the city I think
somewhere I forget some some not a
forest some Park
I forget anyway we're gonna meet up he's
a videographer so he's gonna be blogging
as my cameraman videographer of the day
and then we've got an event gonna meet
up with some pains at four o'clock I
think and then out of Starbucks and then
head into comic-con register get signed
up again into my hotel room gonna be a
long day it's three hours behind so it's
good I just gained two more hours and
see how long you can last step one let's
find leo
[Music]
what's up leo
there's the man
believe nation meet Leo the vlogger with
the mostest
boom it's hot here man it is hot okay
all right nice we're in for a hot ride
guys I'm roasting already this is some
crazy California Heat Leo is just super
chill and this is nothing and I'm I'm
fried we just stepped outside got this
new caramel Lux Frappuccino tastes like
the same thing that's it
they said the whipped cream was cold but
it's already melted look at that the
whipped cream is already gone but look
at this city huh got a palm tree okay
we're gonna get in the car where we're
driving Joshua Tree National Park a
national park Joshua Tree
I don't although they were like no trees
in this National Park I'm gonna roll the
windows down have some fun so we're in
the car about to take off we are gonna
test Leos driving while vlogging with a
camera there we'll see how that works
said he says it's a safe and slow driver
so they'll be fine we're gonna sweat box
it up because we can't actually had the
fan blowing the windows down because
we're recording our conversation but I
realized that I forgot my hoodie on the
airplane which kind of sucks so I asked
me if I want to hang it up I said yes I
never got to get it cuz I was rushing
out here because I like being the first
off the plane
so no hoodie for the entire event
luckily it's insanely hot here so I
don't have to worry about it and
somebody just been gifted a free
believed hoodie the temperature is too
high on the camera the gear is given up
before the people are so we're gonna go
back to my hotel and film because while
I'm happy to sweat box it up with Leo
and have a great conversation we need to
get some footage to record for you guys
and believe nation to learn something
from it too so the gear is giving up
before the people that's what's
important
[Music]
all right I like Leo style we're pulling
over on the side of the road because I
saw this visual back here he wants to
film some content with it so you're
making planes as we go I like it I like
it so this is a setting for our vlog
part one with Leo I love it it's it's
super ghetto
we've got like junk all over the place
barbed wire wired fences noisy highway
it kind of smells like piss I feel like
there's a homeless person who is
sleeping over here before see those mats
the cushion yes I love it I love it I
love it I love it let's build some
awesomeness guys this is how ghetto of a
location we're in right now look at this
I don't think we've ever put this on my
channel ever there's a legit dildo
sitting here in the middle of this
ghetto place that we were filming at
that was in my walking path like this is
the path that we are walking and right
there this is giant dildo listen you can
be great in any environment any
environment I love it you don't have to
be sin to some fancy posh hotel to crush
it we could be in the middle of the
desert with piss smell everywhere in the
baking heat junk all over the place
barbed wire fences and crusty dildos on
the floor and you can still go and crush
your day remember just when you think it
can't get worse it can't get worse look
we have a giant bottle of piss it's a
water bottle it's clear they want a
bottle with yellow liquid inside I
almost stepped on this one too it's
pretty much on the same path that I
walked on the way in here I feel like I
might have touched it I feel amazing
about that and again super grateful to
be in this awesome place
so we decided to check in so get some
air conditioning and look at this
they made a partnership with the Humane
Society of the adoptions
look at that cute guy you know here's to
be freaking out why are you parking me
I'm trying to give you love look see
love oh love Wow
be cute get adopted we're gonna head to
the room and make more content Leo in
the house okay we're looking for a 516
let's go check in here we are okay here
we are
ah that's nice tour bathroom king bed
look at that view oh we could film on
the balcony man look at this I know one
where I make my videos tomorrow that's a
sweet view and then the events are
happening that build in there so we're
pretty close to everything I love it
checked in nice room we're gonna
register for the event officially and
I'm gonna see if I can sneak this guy in
so he could join me for three days and
taking all the YouTube love he has some
friends here too so let's see we can get
Leo and I love I love the last minute
creativity let's try
fingers crossed Tim Schmoyer in the
house Tim is getting his drone ready
really what's your message of the day
Tim why you excited to be here right I
love it it's official official where is
it let's see the name tag we got him in
Leo working with Evan Carmichael I like
it
you gave me a hard time though he gave
me a hard time and now I owe him leo
I owe him hard I owe him big time Leo is
now officially gonna join us for the
next three days learned some YouTube
stuff and being
compadre videographer in arms I'm
excited
we've just been invited into the swagger
room so we got to figure out what of
this stuff we want to take for ourselves
and think he might enjoy some of it too
this is the must-have things 30 feet
tall 30 inches tall okay okay I was
freaking out but 30 inches is still
great okay let's see what else feeling a
box of goodies nice look at this hand
ammonium the tiny hands game high-five
you gotta there you go high-five Nina
whoa like this Hades gonna love this
headshot for sure
Avengers zuru balloons for sure they'll
love that
any of the boy stuff he's gonna love
what's this smash the ball collect them
all all right I like that we'll go read
oh he's gonna love this 13 easy to make
ninjas that's cool let's do paper
monsters gonna love let's grab one isn't
she keeps our fashion queen of these
guys selfie better this morning
these yet each that go let's do one of
those I like it
greedy granny meaning will like that for
sure lots of games happening here build
the boom this looks like a good Hayden
game kids vs. grown-ups trivia game it's
dangerous that's fun but dangerous fun
and dangerous yeah I got story queue
spell like that
oh that's cool that's good story I like
it
my knees were like this Pacha moles
collect egg season two tic-tac-toe just
got so much better
alright and Air Hogs and paw Patrol okay
the box is done yeah but giant box all
the goodies we got to find out how we
shipped this back camera I just got a
car with Bessie we're gonna head off to
a local Starbucks they'll meet up see
who shows up local entrepreneurs have
some fun Thaksin believe
[Music]
all right so meetup is done lots of fun
we're going to the after-party now I'm
gonna go grab got some dinner because it
went later than expected and we're all
starving now so I haven't had a real
meal today it's been Starbucks and
snacks yeah it's been airplane rides all
day so I'm excited to try the yard house
and get some real food we're gonna hit
up some Five Guys Burgers and Fries with
some quick food hi everyone in preparing
for our killer Klowns from outer space s
live the film
yes 30th anniversary concert I had to
see something
inspiration serious inspiration Thank
You Evan done with dinner almost eight
o'clock a weird catelli's ever we are
right now minutes east from here okay
the whole valley is called Coachella got
it so we met at 4:00 supposed to meet
for a little bit it's now four hours in
we're closing up I'm gonna get a ride
back to clamour con I haven't done
anything clammer con yet besides pick up
the swag gonna head back to the hotel
maybe get some work done and maybe just
to meetups see how the vibe goes by
finding the sleep at some point would be
a good idea anyway we'll continue to the
journey
[Music]
okay we're back in hotel gonna check out
the live event see what's happening I'm
not a huge Network here but we'll see
Leo had some transformational moments
for himself
hey what's up guys so I've been really
hesitant posting a video or posting a
picture because you guys know that my
goal was to reach Arjun 70 I'm Way above
that but this guy right here and these
are really awesome people they
encouraged me to do that so here you go
I'm still not giving up on that goal and
I want to share this journey with you
all right take care guys out and others
that we barely captured on camera
please gotta step up his game gotta step
up his game
mr. videographer has to videography
because I've got into my life I changed
his life yeah I was just totally worth
it's totally worth the impact that Leo's
gonna have now is next level I should
wait to see it coming up the fate of the
world has been changing something like
that something like that like yes man I
love that you change one man's life from
the fate of the world has been changed
that's what I'm talking about
this is where we're going there's a
mixer up there literally the stuff I
hate the most
I would rather spend an entire evening
but believe nation then hang out with
people I don't know but we'll see
because of some that I dunno we'll say
hi taking pictures and then head back
into some work
it is almost 11:00 been up for 22 hours
straight
I think you go you'll be around when
there is crashing I let's go let's go we
could talk business for days I love it
we're gonna crash try to get some sleep
and then wake up and do it all over
again tomorrow meet more entrepreneurs
the networking event ended up being
amazing where's the stairs we missed the
stairs
oh it missed the stairs he was always
mrs. Darius see it's too excited to make
the video that we missed the stairs I
ended up talking to a whole bunch of old
faces connecting again then going to
dinner at just to chat and now time to
wind down see if I can I just know
Nina's gone you know Nina's in bed that
upsets me it's 11:00 so it's like 2:00
in the morning for her yeah all right I
won't catch me you know have the message
here tomorrow but hopefully you guys
enjoyed the journey today we'll keep you
tuned in tomorrow see what we're doing
we believe in you
once you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
see you soon